All of this kinda connects to this.
We added sound.
It's a silent movie.
This chart shows all the movies directed or
produced by legendary director D.W.
Griffith in 1912.
He was a Hollywood titan, but most of his
movies?
They were about the same length.
Around 15 minutes, with the exceptions topping
out around a half hour long.
Now look at the run time for 1915’s Birth
of A Nation.
What happened there?
The reason movies changed from 15 minute trifles
to “featured attractions,” can be traced
to one silent movie.
It changed the game in a way that transformed
all movies.
But it wasn’t invented in Hollywood.
It came from 6,000 miles away.
This is a foot — here you go metric people.
Early silent film historians actually talk
about these movies in...feet.
And it makes sense — the same way that measuring
tape comes on a reel, movies come on reels
too.
One reel of film is 1,000 feet, give or take.
That’s 15 minutes or fewer, depending on
what frame rate you play it back at.
In the early days of movies — the 1900s
— almost all movies were about 1,000 feet.
One reel.
15 minutes or fewer.
These short movies were usually screened in
variety shows or a smorgasbord of short films.
You’d drop into a Nickelodeon — a lower-class
theatre where you’d see a bunch of movies
for a nickel — 5 cents.
You’d see Laura Comstock’s Bag Punching
Dog, followed by The Trapeze Disrobing Act,
followed by the first screen adaptation of
Frankenstein.
The whole thing was 14 minutes long - 975
feet.
In America, some of this was enforced by East
Coast movie trusts that controlled and licensed
movie patents for film and projection.
They preferred single and double reel films.
But even renegade filmmakers out in Hollywood
kept movies pretty short.
And, with some exceptions, so did filmmakers
across Europe.
It was just easier to transport and project
one-reel films.
That chart, from the beginning?
It’s not a chart of time, but feet.
And this right here is a thousand feet - that
one reel cutoff.
For the most part, movies were...small.
Until the Italians thought bigger.
Italian movies were were becoming spectacles
in the 1900s.
They were breaking out of the standard 15-minute
short, and trying new things.
By being outside the American system of high-powered
movie trusts, one film in particular was able
to rewrite the rules.
That’s 1913’s Quo Vadis — an epic story
of Romans in the time of Nero.
To tell that story the Italian filmmakers
took 2 whole hours - not 15 minutes.
It was 8,000 feet long!
To get people to see it, Quo Vadis’s promoters
needed to invent a new business model.
Instead of trying to force the long movie
into those movie theaters playing a bunch
of one-reel shorts, promoters rented out classy
concert halls for Quo Vadis alone.
They did the same in the US, at the Astor
Theatre in New York, and playing the “mammoth
photodrama” everywhere from Arkansas to
the future state of Hawaii.
To draw crowds from nickelodeons into those
big halls to watch just one really long thing,
Quo Vadis needed to be special.
It used real Roman locations, thousands of
extras, and the first big stunts - like chariot
races where the actors rode real chariots
and gladiatorial battles with big hits and
realistic weapons.
The posters sold the spectacle — and sold
out seats.
And people noticed.
In the years following the release of Quo
Vadis, DW Griffith, increased the length of
his own movies.
Quo Vadis and other Italian epics were proof
that big movies could work.
Griffith’s movies like “Judith of Bethulia”
crept into feature film lengths - 61 minutes,
a full 4 reels.
He released Birth of a Nation in 1915.
It was sold as the “mightiest spectacle
ever produced” — and a long one clocking
in at 12 reels.
It had big stunts too, like many big battle
scenes.
Now this movie was so controversial that people
called it racist in 1915.
I mean, the KKK are the good guys.
But despite that, it brought the spectacle
of Quo Vadis to Hollywood.
The trusts that wanted to keep movies short
were already fading.
The public’s love of long movies finished
the job.
Birth of a Nation solidified single movies
as a style worth funding and paying for.
And even though today, we don’t measure
movies in feet, Quo Vadis is not a relic.
This chart shows average movie times for the
most popular 25 movies each year, from 1930
on.
This time here?
It’s 2013, 100 years after the 120 minute
Quo Vadis came out.
The running time?
121.4 minutes.
This edition of Almanac’s all about big
changes to the movies that came from outside
Hollywood, and there are a ton of other business
model changes like Quo Vadis, so let me know
some of the ones that you’ve heard about
in the comments.
However, I just to just prove to you one more
time that Quo Vadis really was a huge hit.
This is an ad for “When Ursus Threw the
Bull,” a parody movie that was made in response
to Quo Vadis’s enormous success.